[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
XAVIER DAMMAN: So Storify is a
platform to tell stories using
what people post on
social media.
Right now in the web, we were
in an age where we made it
easier and easier for
people to produce
content, to share content.
And now we are kind of in this
state where there's kind of a
way to match content,
and we try to find
meaning in that content.
We have a bit of information
here, we have a video here, we
have a tweet here.
So often we tell a
story using that.
So this is really what
Storify is all about.
It's how can we connect the
dots, and tell a compelling
story in a really collaborative
way.
NATHAN WHITE: Social networking
as a source for
journalism is becoming more and
more prominent, because
what's happening is the
traditional news outlets and
medias are getting their
news from social media.
Like with the Japanese
earthquake, some of the first
videos and breaking news came
from the social medias from
the individual people.
XAVIER DAMMAN: YouTube is
a fantastic platform.
People with their mobile phone
can so easy share, take a
video and upload
it to YouTube.
It's so well integrated.
And so it's really a no-brainer
that we need to be
able to add YouTube videos
and stories.
And we really had fantastic
support from the developer
advocates at YouTube really
helping us to integrate that,
and really wanted to
create a seamless
experience for the end user.
Our users are people who don't
understand what an API is,
what embedded code
is, necessarily.
So we just created this really
easy to use, drag-and-drop
interface, so we can really
tell better stories, more
engaging stories.
And finding the meaning in the
noise, it's really something,
like kind of the next
step for the web.
And we are really excited
to see that happen.